I'm joining you today from Las Vegas
Nevada tonight the third and final
presidential debate we've had two
presidential debate so far we've had the
vice presidential debate uh funnier than
the last and we'll talk a little bit
more later about what Donald Trump might
be able to do tonight maybe to save this
election it's not looking good and
that's where I want to start we have all
of the latest polling data for you
interestingly usually we have to do this
thing where I say okay here's how the
data looks in a two-way race and then
here's how the data looks in a four-way
race when you include libertarian Gary
Johnson as well as green party candidate
Jill Stein we don't have to do that
today which is it's great for for a
producer Pat because it's just less
graphics to track down but it's also
great because the the lead that Hillary
Clinton now has is effectively the same
nationally whether you do a two-way race
or a four-way race now that doesn't mean
that joel steiner gary johnson might not
have an impact with in one state and
we're going to dig into that but let's
just start with the most general data uh
looking first at the Real Clear Politics
average of recent polling and again this
is including Gary Johnson and jill stein
you'll see that the average lead for
Hillary Clinton is now 7.1 and there's a
lot of I mean I guess the ones emailing
me are primarily Trump supporters but
there's a lot of people who don't really
understand what this number means so
let's let's keep the data up as we talk
about it if you look at all of these
individual polls that are making up this
average for example we've got a fox news
poll where Hillary Clinton is plus six
you've got a bloomberg poll where
Hillary Clinton is plus nine and then
you've got Reuters and CBS News and NBC
News I won't read the list of the 25
recent polls in which Hillary Clinton is
leading the individual poll has its own
margin of error and that margin of error
could be as small as two and a half or
three points and some of them it's
bigger could be five maybe some of these
have trying to look here seems like a
just under five is the largest margin of
error so sometimes people will look at
that average spread and they'll say well
Hillary plus seven if on average these
polls have
margin of error of about four or five to
be generous that means that either
Hillary is plus seven or maybe it's it's
almost a tie right if we take away that
margin of error maybe it's Hillary plus
two what's usually not included in that
very basic analysis for a lot of people
is that the way this polling data works
is if you have a little heed of seven
with a margin of error of five that
means if you imagine the data on a sort
of bell curve the odds the probability
that Hillary Clinton is only leading by
two are exactly the same that Hillary
Clinton is leading by 12 so anybody who
wants to look at the data and say well
that's the maximum that Hillary Clinton
is currently ahead by it might only be
two mathematically you have to say it
could also be 12 right so that says
something that that's very important
that is missing from a lot of analyses
so in in again an average recent polling
Hillary Clinton plus seven let's look
now at the fivethirtyeight.com nate
silver's fivethirtyeight.com forecast
and what this basically does is and
again confusion about what this means
this is an analysis which says if the
election were held today based on all of
the polling data that we have and also
additional factors which nate silver
calls it upholds plus analysis we would
guess that today if you ran a hundred
elections or maybe to make the numbers
easier if you ran the election a
thousand times 876 of those or eighty
seven point six percent of the time
hillary clinton would come out the
victor and a hundred and twenty-four or
twelve point four percent of the times
you run an election simulation with the
data we have today Donald Trump would be
the winner and as you can see Gary
Johnson clocking in it just under 0.1
percent chance of winning based on the
current data the closer we get to
november eighth the more accurately that
this will reflect what is going to
happen on voting day and if you look
back at the trend which we're showing
you here you'll see that Hillary
Clinton's lead sort of grew into July
dropped pretty significantly right at
the beginning of August grew again and
then
very very close at the end of September
then of course we had debate number two
which was just an atrocious and
embarrassing performance for Donald
Trump we had 17 different allegations of
sexual assault against against Donald
Trump uh you've been following it you
know as well as I do what we've had
since then and and the numbers have not
been good for Trump then last thing I
want to talk about this does not we've
been looking at national data this is
basically 50 state elections 51 right 50
plus Washington DC so we have an
electoral college where you need to
achieve 270 electoral votes to win this
election so we really should do an
analysis where we look at the state by
state polls put them on a map and say
okay what are the electoral votes
looking like let's look at the data from
electoral dash vote dot-com from this
morning as you can see you don't need
much more than a kindergarten
comprehension of numbers to know that
339 is a much higher number than 180 one
of which are the respective electoral
vote estimates for Clinton and Trump as
of right now uh this has gone back and
forth but Ohio is now in the tie
category Ohio is worth 18 electoral
votes and you know this is whatever
opinion you sort of have the the way I
suggest doing this is you go to the
website to 72 win dot-com and just start
filling out scenarios you can basically
assign each state to either of the two
candidates any of the four candidates if
you believe Gary Johnson or jill stein
will win any states I don't think so my
map is not going to have them winning
any states and you'll very quickly see
that the scenarios that have Donald
Trump reaching 270 electoral votes
they're not what I would call likely
scenarios right I mean you need to give
Trump ohio and florida and i mentioned
that Donald Trump has already pulled out
of Virginia they've pull resources out
of Virginia down nine there now and
they're basically saying what we're just
not going to get Virginia historically a
state that can go red can go blue North
Carolina is in the leaning towards
Hillary category and you can say
whatever you want about may
making America great again or how good
it was or will be or whatever under
Donald Trump the slogans don't really
matter when you look at the map and you
see that uh unless Donald Trump is able
to do way better way better than Mitt
Romney did uh there's just no way no way
that he can possibly win and it is just
numbers that that's really it October 19
three weeks minus one day before the
election what can Donald Trump do
tonight to change this race in a serious
way or is it at this point just a matter
of Hillary Clinton messing up some major
new scandal that's what I want to get to
next